welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka a friendly
neighborhood spider-man and with
spider-man swinging his way back to the
MCU and bringing a Sony characters with
him though it was time to break down all
of the upcoming confirmed films in the
slate throughout this video we're going
to be discussing everything that you
need to know about the lineup including
venom madam web into the spider verse 2
and more there may be some spoilers here
in regards to plots and so on so if you
don't want to know anything at all about
what could be happening in the movies
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into a breakdown of
all the upcoming Sony Spider Man movies
ok so before we get into this list I
just want to say up top that these might
not be in the order that they're
released I've made this list going off a
tweet from fandom confirming the lineup
so I thought I would just stick to that
order just so there's at least some
basis from a verified account now the
first film in the slate will be Morbius
starring Jared Leto and this has been in
production for a while so it's no real
surprise here and it will likely follow
the same aesthetic of setting up the
villains similar to venom the film will
be released on the 31st of July 2020 and
now we know very little about the plot
at the moment there are a lot of rumors
flying about mainly centered around the
cast and characters JK Simmons will be
reportedly returning as Jay jonah
Jameson and he will apparently be the
first character to crossover between
universes thus connecting the MCU to the
wider Sony verse this comes from dr.
movie news and there have also been
further reports that Tom Holland will
cameo in the post-credits scene of the
movie thus showing that the films are
tied together
who knows maybe they will link the two
with the J jonah Jameson news report
from the ending and far from home
appearing on the news at some point in
the movie and this would allow both
Holland and JK Simmons to feature at the
same time in the film in addition to
this Charlamagne the guard in a recent
radio show said that his friend Tyrese
Gibson who is set to star in the movie
let it slip that it was indeed connected
to the MCU and this was major news upon
its release I've already made a full
video covering this story
so if you
want to watch the clip from the show
that goes into detail on this then I'll
leave that linked above I'll put it at
the end too just in case you want to
stick around for the rest of this video
next up is the already confirmed venom
to which we know has director Andy
Serkis at the helm and it will once
again feature Tom Hardy in the main role
this will likely pick up on the prior
events of venom with the character going
head-to-head with carnage as was teased
in the post-credits scene venom 2 is set
to release on the 2nd of October 2020
and it will follow hot on the heels of
Morbius potentially carrying on directly
from some of the events set in that film
there is also potential here for
Hollander cameo as well and as we know
from leaked reports the actor did she
was seen for the first film but Disney
made the studio cut it due to the
character being dead in infinity war
when promoting zombie land to venom
director Ruben Fleischer did say that it
was always the studio's intention to
have spider-man and venom in the same
film so this could definitely be
building up to that if it isn't put in
place in this movie on top of carnage
venom film shriek is also set to feature
in the film and she will potentially
team up with the antagonist to provide a
double threat for venom the next films
on the slate of spider-man 3 and 4 and
though these probably won't be released
concurrently it does pretty much confirm
that for the next five years at least
spider-man will be directly connected to
the MCU Sony and Disney do seem very
confident announcing two films so we
have to assume that three Scimitar far
from home will end with a cliffhanger
that has to be paid off in a fourth film
the film will apparently focus on Peter
Parker being trialed with Matt Murdock
as his defense lawyer before he goes to
prison to come face-to-face with vulture
and scorpion from then on Peter will
escape and find themselves in a cross
hairs of Kraven the hunter who is trying
to track down the character this is all
rumors for the moment but the first
movie is scheduled to be released on the
16th of July 2021 so we will likely be
getting a lot of announcements in next
six months or so that pay now the plot
details of the film next up is into the
spider verse 2 which is set to release
in 2022 on April 8th recently we had a
release date trailer that dropped on
Twitter from the official spider-verse
account and it hinted at some of the
characters that could be appearing in
the film Sony
producer Amy Pascal recently revealed
that the movie will pick up on a story
thread that was actually cut from the
first movie and then it will also send
her around a love triangle between miles
gwen stacy and an unknown character
we're also going to be getting the
japanese spiderman takuya Yamashiro but
whether he's involved in the love plot
remains to be seen his logo style was
seen for a split second in the release
trailer so it's safe to assume that he
will be appearing in the movie on top of
that we are also getting an all-female
spider-verse spin-off that will pick up
with gwen stacy and other characters
from the spider-verse movies as they go
off on their own adventures we have
rumors that silk and Jessica tree will
be appearing and diehard Spidey fans
will no doubt be happy to see these
characters on the big screen finally the
next item in the slay is the Kraven the
hunter movie Kraven is a really really
underrated spider-man film and there's
actually a lot of depth of the character
on a psychological level Kraven is
absolutely fascinating and in the comic
books he's one of the only villains to
truly beat spider-man now this is a
weird one as the villain will apparently
feature in spider-man 3 so whether this
will launch before that or after the
events of it remains to be seen if
anything on this list doesn't end up
going ahead I can see it being this as
it just seems a bit too much in terms of
time I wouldn't know whether it's best
to tell a prequel or to do a sequel but
Kraven did die in the comics at which if
spider-man 3 is gonna adapt Cravens last
hunt seems like a misstep
anyway we will see but this seems like
the most difficult one to pull off in
terms of time scales from the slate next
up there are actually five films
centered around side characters in the
spider-man universe and each one of
these is apparently getting their own
standalone film the five films are black
cat silver sable a silk jackpot and
lastly Night Watch now is this a good
idea personally I think that it's a bit
of over saturation however we did hear
that Sony was developing TV shows
centered around spider-man characters so
this could be the Avenue that they take
these down whilst they are announced as
part of the film's slate I think this
seems far more likely and just makes a
lot more sense
we know that Sony want to make TV shows
for they carry
and who better to pick to kick-start
that universe after that is the Madame
web movie and this has the potential to
be the film that opens up spider-man to
the multiverse when it was first
announced there was quite a lot of
backlash online with many people asking
why characters who've never had a
standalone comic or getting their own
standalone movie this seemed a bit like
Sony are completely milking this entire
thing and honestly I'm not too sure on
this one are people really all that
interested in my damn web I guess we
will see but personally this may be a
pass from me unless it's something truly
special and lastly on the list is the
sinister six film now again this is an
obvious one as Sony have been trying to
build a sinister six movie for decades
now and it looks like they finally have
the opportunity to actually pull it off
this time
I'm guessing everything mentioned prior
to this will build up towards it with
there being a team of not only villains
but also good guys that go head-to-head
in this movie who knows this might
actually be the unannounced spider-man
full movie as it makes the most sense to
have the villains face off against him
actually think that venom will be the
wild card here and the final battle will
be decided by which side he falls on and
it could be great but it also could be
terrible and hey I guess time will tell
anyway that's everything that we know
about the upcoming Sony verse slate and
I have to say there are some really
interesting projects in here and I hope
that they all get weaved well into the
MCU as a thing there could be a lot of
potential here for some amazing
crossovers into the spider verse 2 is
probably the film that I'm most excited
for as that first film is a masterpiece
of animation storytelling and in general
it's just a brilliant comic book movie
the rest looks solid though and I think
with the ability to integrate spider-man
into their films the universe will fly
especially venom which always felt like
it was lacking an appearance from the
webhead either way i'm really excited
and i can't believe that these films are
just a couple of years away as alongside
the MCU releases we have a lot to look
forward to now I'd of course love to
hear your thoughts on the slide and
which film that you're most excited for
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our full breakdown of the news that
Doctor Doom will be the main Vil
and black panther too we go over the
report and give our thoughts on how it
could work so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
you want to come chat to me after the
video that make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey or head
over to my discord server which should
be linked in the description below we
drop videos on there early so if you
want to see stuff before anyone else
then that's the best place to be it's
free to join and we have an awesome
community so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the Marvel phase 3 part 2
boxer blu-ray which contains Black
Panther infinity war and Game Captain
Marvel and more and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the Sony slay in the
comments section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of
December and the set will be shipped out
from then to our gets the prize so best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is a channel for people who are super
into superheroes so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thank
you for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you